well i have to also say congratulations  though because you're getting inducted  into the football hall of fame this year  that's  insane i i gotta be honest with you for  a sports ball  uh person who doesn't know a lot about  it i kind of figured you're already part  of it i don't know you're like a legend  i was  i'm very honored uh you have to be  retired at least  five years from the nfl to be eligible  so i'm very honored i love football  growing up i love the history of it so  to kind of be  on the same team as some of the great  players that have played  uh in the past uh it's a real honor and  for me kelly  i'm sure like you it's been a chance to  reflect on all the people that have been  a part  of kind of my football journey right  coaches teammates family  behind the scenes support staff i'm  looking forward to celebrating together  yep i'm still here just waiting for you  to subscribe  if you don't i'll be trapped in this box  forever